欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,我们接着讲产品优化的八个指标
选对指标四半公倍,有时候我们对指标不理解
对数据判断不准确
就会导致我们无头绪的去优化
那么这种有可能就造成我们浪费时间
第二个,有可能好的产品被你优化没了
所以一定要重视这八个指标
根据数据去优化对应的内容
首先我们在PC首页搜索的时候
是不是会出现产品的列表
那产品列表里面的这些产品的信息
包含哪些内容呢
比如说第一个主图, 标题, 价格, 启定量
以及它的一些发货日期
如果进到产品详情页里面
可能会有优惠券
第二个就是
其他的一些具体的内容
都会在这个详情页里面去展示
所以说我们最终通过我们看到的这些维度
模拟买家去搜索产品的时候
看到的这些维度来进行一个判断
最终我们就去预估哪些指标
哪些因素会影响到我们对应的哪个数据
通过数据来反推
我问哪些指标是有问题的
然后再进行针对性的优化就可以了
那么它的具体的指标是什么
第一个主图
第二个就是关键词跟标题
第三个就是QQ和价格
如果你的启定量或者价格太高的时候
有可能就会导致你寻盘转化下降
第四个就是评价分
如果你的评价太低
那么这个产品可能给人的印象就不好
客户可能就不太想要这种低评价的产品
第五个就是产品想营业的综合排序
比如说你这个产品想营业是吧
点进去之后看到内容跟其他的一些排版
比如说A内容先展示B内容先展示C内容先展示
他们的先后顺序排序不一样
那么客户看到的概率就是不一样的
那么对于寻盘的转化也就是会产生不一样的结果
所以你要重视产品详情页里面的内容的一个顺序排列
以及呈现的内容是什么
这样是会直接影响到你的寻盘转化的
我们在优化产品的时候
产品的详情页的内部也是可以进行优化的
第六个就是折扣券和关联营销组合购
还有一个就是场景搭配在AP里面才有的
那么这些折扣跟优惠
对于客户发寻盘的吸引力是非常大的
不要小看这个板块
所以为什么我们平常要去设置一些折扣券跟优惠券
优惠券针对的是普通寻盘品或者是寻盘品
折扣券针对的是一些
PATS产品或者是你的半托产品
这些都是可以的
第七个就是你的物流费太贵了
也会导致你的寻盘转化很少
或者是咨询很少的
有些客户他是懂得如何去输入地址来测试自己的
运费大概在哪个区间的
如果他一测试发现你的物流太贵了
那他还给你发寻盘就很渺茫
所以我们在设置物流的时候
一定要把产品的体积和重量准确的设置
这样的话就不会导致物流费太高太贵
第八个就是
访客国家不精准的时候
也是会导致寻盘转化率非常低
以及TM非常低的
比如说你这款产品主打的是美国的
你的价格起定量都是针对美国设置的
那么如果你的这个产品都是非洲的客户看到
那么他很难接受你的这个价格跟起定量
所以就会导致他只看不买
只看不发信息给你
所以只有访客跟点击量增长
但是这个产品的寻盘是下降的
是吧
那么最后我们来讲一下
刚才讲漏的一点
比如说你的主图为什么很好
但是点击率很低
有可能就是你所对应的关键词
比如说A关键词
它排名在PC首页PC首页
它排名在太后面了
排名在底部
或者是第二第三页
这样就会导致它的一个曝光量虽然有
但是它的点击就很少
所以说点击率就低
这个跟你的关键词排名的位置
有极大的关系
所以曝光高点击率低
不代表着你的主图一定是有问题
有可能是你要去看一下
那个关键词
是不是高曝光低点击
是不是这个关键词的排名的位置
太后面了
都在底部这些位置
客户如果一搜索的时候
往下拉
可能就相当于没有真正的看到你这个产品
所以就不会点击
最后面我们一定要注意
一个噸就是耗款跟高转化的产品
不要优化标题
一定不要轻易的优化标题
如果你要优化标题
一定是在等产品处于下滑的阶段
或者是说循盘持续下降的阶段
再去针对性的优化标题
如果他在高转化或者是循盘量很好的时候
即使他的流量少
关键词覆盖少的情况下
你也不要去优化标题先
先让他在最高状态的时候
给你带来更多的价值
所以这个一定要注意
因为这种问题是非常常见的
而且非常多人陷进这个坑里面
所以一定要提前规避
一定要警醒
接下来我们来后台看一下
比如说我们在搜索一个关键词的时候
你看我们看到的就是这些内容
这些内容
你要思考这些内容
对客户有什么样的吸引力
以及哪些维度会影响客户的哪些行为
比如说这里我们还可以在这里
你看可以进行一个切换的模式
切换的模式之后就不一样
因为每个客户的片号不一样
那么他在这里展示的样式就不一样
那么我们随便点一款产品进来之后
你看进来之后
你看这个产品就有设置到这个折扣
你看是不是更有吸引力折扣
有些产品如果他设置了优惠券
那么他优惠券在这个板块
是不是也能够让客户停留一下
或者是对这个产品更加感兴趣一点
这种情况
接下来我刚才讲的就是产品详情页的内容
你看评价
你看这个评价是吧
为什么阿里直接就把这个板块重点往前移呢
就是为了增加买家的信任
以及获得他们的青睐
快速给你发行盘
所以说一定要重视这个
接着就是你的产品详情页的一个具体内容的排序
你要去看一下他的内容
这个板块
以及你要展示的这些详情页的内容
一个是内容和一个就是内容的先后顺序
都会影响你这个产品
你发行盘的一个机会和概率
比如说我们再看一下这个产品
你看这个是半拖的
也是一样的
你要按照这些指标去参考
就去看哪些指标对应的影响买家的哪些行为
我们通过这些指标的数据
也就是在产品分析里面
360里面去看那些数据
通过数据的这些维度去判断一下
我们要优化哪些具体的指标就可以了
好了
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们接着讲
关于产品优化的实战方法